foreign
[Music]
because I feel like the trillionaire
guys didn't bite on the apoll episode
that FTX sex tape would be disgusting
yes I agree I totally agree I don't know
why they weren't they weren't like
giving it yeah I mean it's all like a
bunch of
like amphetamined up Engineers that
haven't seen the sun yeah in like weeks
all these girls that are getting on Tick
Tock right now and snitching on
themselves about Partners they had that
didn't like wash their ass yeah that's
who'd be in there yeah well I've been I
haven't seen those you haven't seen them
no bro what are these young women you
know this is the this is the poison of
the internet God bless them
you know they see these people sharing
personal stories and they go I want to
share a personal story right
I used to date a guy who never washed
his ass
and they'll describe
what does that even mean never wash your
ass like literally shower like you would
never get it in the crack and so what
it's just like built up to just yep yep
Gunk algae
just clay yeah
Lake clay yeah
what gets in between tiles oh yeah like
[ __ ]
like bathroom costs yeah yeah
all the built-up yeah sure yeah
they had a whole bunch of built up [ __ ]
in their ass
you're straight out with it that White
Lotus episode is on your mind dude it's
on your mind I mean you never know you
know sometimes nerds they like because
they're all men can lay it down
they're messed up and examine a gigantic
dick not even that he he might have just
been average but he might have just been
like he might have had Rhythm yeah
because you know doubt it
It's probably hard to be rhythmic on
amphetamines yeah yeah you know yeah
probably doing crazy [ __ ] yeah like like
can't focus on the sex yeah they need
stop and yeah start doing things
thinking about options like short my
tether yeah yeah sure my tether I was I
was picturing more scary stuff like just
drawing symbols on the wall
foreign
they're coming
naked with a boner talking about kpis
all of a sudden yeah I know that was
harsh for me to say their orgy would be
disgusting but it would be
I think it'd be highly relatable though
I mean
any orgy is disgusting that's true you
think about it if you really think about
what go like in orgy oh yeah no no no
I'm not saying Attractive people would
make it
um because I'm saying they're not
attractive but yeah
to some people there yeah yeah
uh each other each other yeah
I mean do you see what's what SBF used
to look like when he started the company
no you haven't no see he's leaned out
little nerd like he's got like no but
like healthier vibrant yeah don't you
think yeah he's got like a certain glow
to him this is like I do oh he's been
seeing fluorescent light in an office
for uh like three straight years yeah he
also stressing about the fact that he's
running a Ponzi scheme you know that
takes a toll on someone yeah 100 his
eyes look like he's seen some [ __ ] he
came back from hell yeah for this
picture yeah
he's just a young boy in that first one
like I can't wait to start my Christmas
I want to start a crypto company
you want to start a crypto company I
want to do something with the blockchain
Bitcoin to the Moon
no this is all he hears in his head
[Music]
give us the coin
he lost 10 billion dollars and he's
chilling in the Bahamas still
nothing's happened I don't I don't even
think the SEC has like launched an
investigation
he declared bankruptcy they installed
the same guy that was the CEO of Enron
after they declared bankruptcy actually
did you see yesterday there was like
this uh
um they had they had listed their like
payables like there's their you know
checks that they owed basically yeah and
one of them like the topmost one was an
AWS bill that was like 3.5 million
dollars and then the third one was a
bill for Margaritaville Bahamas for like
50k wow just running running up a tab
Perpetual tab right before their orgy
you know where they're going That's That
Mountain Dew urine yeah they could have
had a piss org he would have smelled
fine it smelled good honestly would have
been cleaning the place yeah you think
they're all like piss pigs nah that's
what I say I think that orgy be really
relatable I don't you know I don't think
they'd be doing like movie or porn
stroke right I think it would have just
looked super regular yeah like five
people just regular just
yeah just busting in 45 seconds and then
oh well guess it's your turn yeah
okay gotta get back to it yeah
you know these jira tasks aren't gonna
write themselves
bro you think
it's like just like wires backhands in
the background
I I think it's so
generous of you to think that these guys
are [ __ ] with their pants around
their ankles
you think they're all well I guess
that's how they pee at the urinal yeah
I wonder if these chains offer
like a corporate invoicing situation
where it's like oh yeah you know we'll
probably do a bunch of corporate parties
here and yeah like they host them for
like in the back room or whatever yeah
yeah orgy yeah yeah for their orgy
I picture them getting I think that'd be
the other funny part I think they
actually get fully naked
to the socks yeah for the orgy you're at
Margaritaville for the orgy yeah it
could be both yeah I think they have
giant I think they get like Vats of
Margarita and put them in like baby
pools and like they get really yeah they
get really sticky you know nice
sounds like a milk party Jesus
ft FTX Squad firing with milk yeah
that's the term right yeah firing yeah
is it when they're like getting drunk
firing I swear I've heard them say that
really yeah
like sending
it's I think it's like similar yeah SBF
and Bradley Martin in the Bahamas
yo I'm here with a [ __ ] billionaire
it's me up here
[Music]
oh my God
[Music]
it's time for you to crush this Market
absorb all the funds from from the human
race
collect all the money from the human
race or
yeah sorry they were they were talking
to me again
what no we're gonna stop taking those
[ __ ] amphetamines man bro you guys
I'm not I'm Stone sober for sure man
let's change that
Margaritaville or what
gets him to sign the NDA then take all
their money in their account then crush
this Market we will return the housing
market to what he wants was red
laughs